Voiceover: At its core,
bitcoin is just basically
a chain of digital signatures
that really reflect
the coin's path through
the bitcoin ecosystem.
And, you know what? I think it's actually
conceptually easier to think of bitcoins
as collective entries into a ledger
rather than as a physical coin
because if you think
about it, in a ledger,
you have a record of
transaction histories,
which is what happens in bitcoin,
whereas with the physical coin,
it's more, like, memory-less.
There's no history in a physical coin
of where that coin has
really been in the past.
In this context, you can
think of a transaction
as just a digitally-signed
declaration by one party
of its intent to transfer some bitcoins
that they possess to
another set of parties.
And when I say one party possesses
a certain number of bitcoins,
I really just mean here that
there are some previous
transactions on record
that everybody's agreed to
in which the party now
transferring the bitcoins
was itself the recipient
of a previous transfer
of those bitcoins, all right?
Now, I realize it's a bit convoluted,
so maybe to help better
understand the mechanics
of a transaction,
I can do an example of what would happen
in the context of an
actual bitcoin transaction.
Let's say we have a party,
and let's call her Alice,
which is the common
name we use for parties
in cryptographic schemes,
and let's say she wants to transfer
some bitcoins to Bob,
and let's say she would like,
has an intention of wanting to transfer
50 bitcoins to Bob.
Now, remember that anybody who transacts
in the bitcoin ecosystem
is actually not transacting
under their real name,
or their actual name,
but rather they are known
by a very specific identity,
a pseudonym within the bitcoin ecosystem,
and that identity, that
pseudonym is actually
that actually corresponds
to a public verification key
for a digital signature scheme.
So, in this case, let's
say Alice's identity
in the system is really some
public verification key,
which we'll call VK of A,
so Alice's verification key,
and in the context of Bob,
let's say his public
verification key is VK sub B.
So, these are keys that are used
within digital signature schemes,
and so we can assume
that Alice has generated
this key at some point, and
that she made it public,
and that Bob did the same thing,
and so now they both have identities
within the system,
and these identities are
just sequences of numbers
that correspond to public
keys for verification
in the context of a
cryptographic digital signature.
All right?
Now, remember, that these values
also correspond to private values,
so each person who's got a public key
will have a corresponding private key,
associated with that public key,
and in this case, we'll
call the private key,
or the secret key, which is, in fact,
a signing key in this
context, SK of Alice,
and we'll say that Bob's
signing key is SK of Bob.
Okay?
And they're going to basically
keep these keys private.
Now let's say that Alice
herself had received
in the past,
three transactions of
bitcoins from other parties.
Let's say she got 25 bitcoins from Carol,
and we'll call Carol VK
of C to associate that
with her key,
let's say she got 20 public,
or 20 bitcoins, rather, from David,
and let's say she got 20
more bitcoins from Ted.
Okay?
So these are,
these bitcoins correspond
to different people
that provided Alice with
bitcoins in the past,
and so as you can see,
Alice now has an aggregate of 65,
which is 20 plus 20 plus 25 bitcoins,
and so as a result,
she has a sufficient number to be able to
transfer 50 of those
bitcoins to Bob, okay?
So to start off with, a
transaction from Alice to Bob
for 50 bitcoins will
contain information about
these previous transactions,
so each of these previous transactions
where Alice received some bitcoins,
these will have been recorded
in the bitcoin ecosystem,
so they're going to be made public,
just like every other transaction,
and so what Alice can actually do
is she can take some representation
of these transactions and include them
as part of the new transaction with Bob,
basically as an anchor point to say,
"Hey, I received these previous bitcoins,
"and now I'm going to transfer
"some portion of these
bitcoins to you, Bob."
Okay?
So, in this context, actually,
she does not need to include the full
transaction details in the
actual transaction record
to Bob.
What she can instead do
is take the transaction details and apply
a cryptographic hash function to them
to get a series of digests
for each transaction.
So in this case, let's
say she has a digest
that corresponds to the
transaction of Carol,
she'll have a digest that corresponds
to the transaction from David,
and she'll have a digest that corresponds
to the transaction from Ted, okay?
And she'll basically include
each of these digests
into the transaction record,
and what these [trackers] allow you to do,
or really allow anyone
to do, for that matter,
is they can verify the chain of ownership
of these bitcoins,
because they can simply take
all the previous transaction records,
which, again, are made public.
They can apply
cryptographic hash functions
to these different transaction records,
and they can verify that
these cryptographic hashes,
when applied to those transaction records
provide you back with the
values D sub C, D sub D,
and D sub T,
and that, in turn, provides you with
some type of a cryptographic guarantee
because we're using
cryptographic hash functions,
we have a cryptographic guarantee that,
that Alice was the ultimate recipient of
these transactions from
these different parties.
We have this nice history
that we can record,
and that we can essentially
ascertain in this fashion.
All right?
Because we're using
cryptographic hash functions,
we now have some assurance that Alice
couldn't have so easily
cheated the system,
all right?
So, at this point in the transaction,
and maybe I'll kind of draw a line
so you can kind of see
where the transaction
details are recorded.
So at this point of the transaction,
we have details about Alice's ownership
of these 65 bitcoins,
and she has enough information
in that transaction
so that anybody can verify
that she possessed these coins.
You can think of this part
of the transaction, really,
as representing the input,
the input to the transaction.
Now, in addition to the input portion
of the transaction,
there's typically also an output portion.
I'm going to put that
output portion up here,
but let me label it,
and so for starters,
in the output portion,
she has to include,
or Alice has to include
a list of recipients
for her bitcoins,
and since Alice wants to,
let's say, transfer these bitcoins to Bob,
she has to specify Bob's
identity in the system,
which, in fact, as you mentioned earlier
was Bob's public key,
so we'll say that she'll
mention V sub K of B,
and she also has to record
and mention at this stage
how many coins she
wants to transfer to Bob
and as we said earlier,
we were going to assume
that Alice wanted to transfer exactly 50
of her bitcoins to Bob, okay?
So she's going to
specify the number of 50.
Actually, in reality, she'll
specify another number,
but it's going to represent
50 bitcoins for Bob, okay?
Now, in order for Alice to get back change
because she has 65
bitcoins kind of coming in,
and she is only giving 50 back to Bob,
what she might then do is decide that
she's going to specify
14 of those bitcoins
to be returned back to her
in the form of change,
so 14 of those bitcoins
are going to be reassigned
back to Alice's public key, all right?
And what Alice will then
do is she's going to take
all of this data, this transaction data,
this input and this output,
and she's going to
digitally sign that data,
and she's going to use her signing key,
her signing key,
to digitally sign all this data,
like you would with a digital signature,
and she's going to append that signature
to the actual contents of
the transaction record,
and that'll effectively
bind Alice's identity
with the transaction record itself.
And the reason it's going to bind it is
we're using a digital signature scheme,
and so anybody who possesses
Alice's public key,
which, again, is made public,
can validate that only
Alice could have created
this block because only Alice, in theory,
can come up with the signature
that corresponds to her public key
because she's the only
person who, in theory,
should possess the private signing key
corresponding to her
public key, all right?
Then all of this data will
actually be broadcast out,
so this transaction data
will then get broadcast out
to all the different peers and the nodes
in the bitcoin network.
Everybody in the bitcoin network
will basically know now that
VK sub A is trying to send
50 bitcoins to VK sub B.
Now, at this point,
you may have noticed a
slight discrepancy here
that Alice started off with 65 coins,
kind of on the input side,
but on the output side,
she only has 50 plus 14,
or 64 coins that are being accounted for.
So there's this issue,
what happens with this one,
one last remaining coin?
There's kind of this one
implicit coin hanging around
that has not been accounted for,
and what we're going to do with that coin
is that coin is actually going to be used
as a transaction fee.
Alice is basically saying
that this one leftover coin
should be provided as transaction fee
to what's known as a bitcoin miner.
A bitcoin miner, as I
mentioned in a previous video,
is basically an entity
in the bitcoin system.
Anybody can be a bitcoin miner, actually,
but it's a node in the bitcoin network
who engages, really, in the effort
to help with the broader
validation of this transaction.
So what do I mean by broader validation?
Well, if you think about it,
at this point, we've just used
cryptographic hashing and
digital signing to validate
that Alice at some point possessed
the requisite bitcoins in the system,
and that she not only publically announced
her intention to transfer
some of the bitcoins to Bob,
but she digitally signed
that public pronouncement,
if you will, as a result of which,
her public verification key,
which is her identity
in the bitcoin system,
is now bound to that transaction.
But, what Bob doesn't know yet,
even though he knows all of these things
and he can validate them,
what Bob doesn't know yet
is whether Alice tried to,
let's say, previously sign,
or sign those exact same
coins to somebody else.
Maybe there's another party.
Let's say Alice has a friend named Eve.
Maybe Alice decided she's going to send
these bitcoins not only to Bob,
but also she's going to try to send
these same bitcoins to Eve,
and Bob at this point may
not have the assurance
that Alice has not tried to engage
in these types of shenanigans, all right?
And so the tricky part here is that
even though all the
transactions we've talked about
have been made public
because the bitcoin
requires all transactions
to be made public,
we still need a mechanism,
and this has to be a
decentralized mechanism
that does not require a
trusted third party, per se.
We need a decentralized
mechanism for agreeing,
really, on the order in which transactions
actually took place,
so that we can resolve any disputes
about someone trying to
double spend their coins.
It's that requirement, that timestamp,
that decentralized time
stamp, if you will,
which is where bitcoin miners play
a very important role in
the bitcoin ecosystem,
and I'll talk about how that works
and how we deal with
transaction time stamping
in subsequent videos.